حادثه مؤسفه متكرره تثار بين الحين والاخر
اشعلتها مجددا قضيه عض كلب مدير احد
البنوك ما تسبب له باصابه بالغه ادخلته في
غيبوبات
الاعلاميه اميره شنب المتهم بالمسؤوليه عن
الكلب احتياطا على ذمه التحقيق معه ووجهت
لصاحب الكلب تهمه تسبب بالخطا في اصابه
جاره باهماله وترك الكلب دون قيد او تكميم
كما تم حجزه وعرض الكلب على مديريه الطب
البيطري وتبين خلوه من اي اعراض غير
طبيعيه وطلقيه كافه التطعيمات وايضا وجود
ترخيص بحيازته رغم انه من فصيله بيتبول
المحظور استيرادها دوليا القضيه فتحت
مجددا ملف المسؤوليه عن مثل هذه الحوادث
كذلك الشروط الخاصه بتربيه الكلاب خاصه
الانواع المفترسه منها التفاصيل مصر مع
سمر بشات ونعود بالنقاش
ضجه شهدتها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
الايام الاخيره بعد واقعه هجوم كلب من
فصيله بيتبول على رجل في احدى التجمعات
السكنيه الراقيه ما احدث به اصابات بالغه
في الاوتار والاعصاب ادى الى دخول في
غيبوبه حتى اليوم
القصه بدات عندما كان الاب عائدا الى بيته
مع ابنه ومعه مشتريات فوجد كلب جيرانه في
الحديقه خلف سور صغير توجه بعدها لشقه
الجار للتاكيد له على السيطره على الكلب
وفور فتح الباب هاجم الكلب الرجل ممزقا
اوتارا واعصابا في القدم واليد ما استدعى
خضوعه لجراحه دقيقه
واثناء الجراحه توقف قلب الرجل لمده نصف
ساعه ثم عاد ينبض من جديد ولكنه دخل في
غيبوبه تامه تم القبض على صاحب الكلب الذي
لم يكن هو وزوجته موجودين في البيت اثناء
الحادث كما تم ايداع الكلب بمستشفى
البيطري حيث قال احد شهود العيان انه سبق
وعاقر احد الجيران
هذه الواقعه اثارت قضيه امتلاك الكلاب
والقوانين المنظمه لهذا الامر كما تقدمت
النائبه امال عبد الحميد بمقترح للبرلمان
بمنع استيراد كلاب من فصيله بيتبول
هذا الحادث فتح ملف اقتناء الكلاب وخاصه
في الاحياء الراقيه التي يحب اصحابها
استيراد كلاب من نوعيات غير مالوفه كما
اثارت الجدل مره اخرى حول قضيه كلاب
الشوارع التي تسبب مخاوف للعديد من السكان
من ناحيه او ما يتعلق بالتوازن البيئي من
ناحيه اخرى سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من
القاهره
[موسيقى]
على كل من القاهره ينضم الينا المحامي
بالنقد المستشار محمد طاهر عبر الهاتف
تنضم الينا ايضا زوجه الضحيه الدكتوره
ايمان عبد المحسن اهلا بكما ابدا معك
دكتوره ايمان زوجك تم يعني اول شيء لو
تحدثين اكثر حتى نفهم في ظل تضارب
الروايات ما الذي حصل تحديدا
صباح الخير
بشكركم على اهتمامكم بالحادث بتاع جوزي هو
ايه اللي حصل زي ما انتم ذكرتوا ان هو كان
راجع البيت فعلا ومعاه مشتروات هو وابني
وكان هم جيراننا في الدور الارضي في نفس
العماره الكلب سايب في الجنينه وكان يعني
بيبص لجوزي وابني وهم طالعين اسرع تحفظيه
شويه فجودي ده خوفا من حدوث اي حاجه دخل
يحذرهم ان هم يتاكدوا ان الكلب مقفول عليه
او يعني في احكام والسيطره عليه لان هم
صوره الجنينه بتاعهم مش عادي يصور
جدا والكلب كذا مره خرج منه واحنا كانت
بعض المشتريات فيها لحوم فكانت هتبقى
ريحتها نفذه ومستفزه للكلب فكانت لسه في
عربيه فكان هنطلع وينزلوا من البيت كذا
مره فده سبب ان هو خبط عليهم عشان يتاكدوا
ان هم حاول زوجك دكتوره ايمان يعني حاول
زوجك انه
يدفع الكلب يبعده يعني ضربه مثلا زي اي
حاجه خالص هو كان داخل من باب العماره على
يمين العماره المدخل الجنينه بتاعتهم
الكلب كان واقف في مدخل الجنينه ظاهر
للعين ان هو شايف في الجنينه وهو سور
الجنينه فممكن يطلع ينط منه عادي
فهو دخل جوه العماره وخبط على باب الشقه
العادي
باب الشقه فتحت المساعده او اللي هي
المربيه اللي عند عند الجيران في البيت
فتحت وهي بتفتح الباب كانت كلب واقف جنبها
كلب هاجم طيب دكتوره هو سبقا حصل مشاكل مع
هذا الكلب هل سبق ان تم تقديم تحذيرات
الجيران بخصوصه
هو هرم قبل كده على احد الجيران وكان
معاها برضه هاسكي فده كلب كبير وقوي هجم
عليه واصابه اصابات بالغه حتى كان من
ضمنها كسر في الفك بتاع الكلب وجارتنا
نفسها كان عندها كذا اصابه في كتفها
وكدمات كثيره جدا واعتقد كان عندها شك في
الكتف كانت حادثه من حوالي سنه ونصف حين
حدوث الحادث ده هم مشوا الكلب من البيت
حوالي شهر او شهرين مش متذكره ورجع ثاني
استاذ محمد
كان عندنا كلب وبرضو كنا ماشيين بيه عادي
لسه هندخل من باب العماره لقيناه نط من
السور وهاجا مع الكلب بتاعنا بدون اي سبق
انذار
استاذ محمد اليوم يعني استمعنا الى هذه
القصه وكل الناس عارفه طب شو الصوره
القانونيه المخرج القانوني لهكذا قضيه من
يحاسب وعلى من تقع المسؤوليه بالاساس
اولا قبل مبدا حديثي يعني اتمنى الشفاء
العاجل للسيد المصاب بسعادتك بسبب الواقع
ديت وربنا ان شاء الله يتم عليه بالشفاء
وان شاء الله يرجع لبيته سالم وغانم
بمناسبه الشهور الكريمه الشهر الكريم اللي
احنا داخلين عليه
اولا سعادتك احب بس ادي تعريف سعادتك عن
الكلاب البيتبول قبل ما اخش في الناحيه
القانونيه الكلاب البيتبول دي سعادتك من
الانواع الشرسه جدا هي والكلاب العود
فايلر وفي 18 نوع من الكلاب دي شرسه جدا
جدا جدا لدرجه ان دوله زي كندا بتحذر دخول
هذه الكلاب الى كندا ليه لان هي كلاب شرسه
جدا بطبيعتها على سبيل المثال الكلب
البيتبول صاحب الواقعه معلومه لحضراتكم هو
في قوه ربع اسد اقول تاني هو في قوه ربع
اسد يعني اربع كلاب من البيتبول يمثلوا
اسد كامل فده قوي جدا وشرس جدا
بالاضافه ان طبعا ربنا خلقه من نوع
المهاجم والشرس
فاداله فك ليس فك مستوي زي اسنان البشر لا
او الفك ما بيبقاش مظبوط كده للسنان فوق
بعضيها بالمنظر ده لا الفك في تجويفات
يعني ساعتك السنان لما بيقفل بيدخل جوه
بعضيها بالمنظر دوت بيدخل جوه بعديها
بالمنظر ده من نوعيه التماسيح والقروش
بمعنى ادق ان العضه بتاعته سعادتك ممكن
تجيب قطن في العظم وتهدف طبعا في جميع
الانسجه والاورده فهو طبيعته شرس من نوعيه
مثلا النمور والاسود والكلام ده كله فطبعا
دي محظور سعادتك دخولها مثلا دوله زي كندا
بتحذر دخولها تماما
للاسف الشديد في القانون المصري اه بالاسف
الشديد بقى في القانون المصري ندخل فيها
القانون المصري ينظم كل حاجه طبعا لكن
للاسف الشديد ما كانش لسه الطفره دي دخلت
علينا في مصر اللي هي طفره تربيه الكلاب
بالنسبه حضرتك للناس الاغنياء بالذات لان
طبعا تكلفه تربيه الكلب في مصر مكلفه
مكلفه جدا يعني عشان اربي الكلب زي زي
الفل
ليس محظور امتلاكه في مصر اليوم اتحدث عن
ضحيه دخل مرحله الغيبوبه وبصابات بالغه
وصاحب الكلب تم حبسه على ذمه التحقيق ما
العقوبات المنتظره في هذه الحاله قانونيا
ماذا سيحصل
هو قانونا سعادتك هنقول لسعادتك اذا
اتكلمنا عن الماده 377 فقره اتنين ده
سعادتك في قانون العقوبات بيقول لك الماده
دي بتقول ايه النزيه سعادتك غرامه 100
جنيه فقط لا غير غرامه 100 جنيه في حاله
ان واحد يكون مسؤول عن حيوان ولم يحسن
السيطره عليه يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال
وقع زي اللي احنا فيها او مثلا حصان ماشي
في الشارع رفس واحد فاموته او احدث به
اصابه دي القانون المصري يساعد لك الماده
377 فقره اتنين بتقول غرامها 100 جنيه لكن
القوانين المدني القانون المدني بيقول لك
يلزم سعادتك التعويض في الماده 176 من
القانون المدني بيقول لك المسؤوليه عن عن
عمل الغير المسؤوله عن
عن استعمال الاشياء فحارس الحيوان هو
مسؤول عنه اذا احدث اصابه بالغير فهو ملزم
بتعويض المجني عليه لكن طبعا بعد انتشار
هذه الظاهره من سد الثغرات القانونيه
حصل تشريع في مجلس الشعب والزم طبعا طبقا
لقانون البيئه لقانون اربعه لسنه 94 ان هو
يعمل سعادتك يعمل ايه بقى
يجرا هذه الوقعات والزم فيها سعادتك الحبس
من سنتين لخمس سنوات للمسؤول عن الحيوان
الذي احدث ضرر من غير يعني اذا افترضنا
اذا افترضنا الكلب لو هاجم المجني عليه من
رقبته كان طبعا هيموته هيقتله فكل ما في
الامر القولون المصري قام بتشريع نص خاص
بهذه الواقعه والزم فيها الحبس من سنتين
لخمس سنوات
وانا انصحك اوكي اتفضل تنصح
تفضلي
طيب دكتوره ايمان اليوم امام كل هذه
المعطيات وشفنا كمان المخرج القانوني له
بدنا نعرف كيف صحه زوجك الان وضعه الان في
المستشفى وماذا تطالبون بعد هذا الاعتداء
الوحشي من قبل الكلب
والله انا صحت جوزي لسه لحاله حرجه جدا
لسه مفيش اي وعي اه اجهزه الجسم بتستجيب
ولكن تدريجي
وستيل برضو الحاله لسه مش مستقره يعني
ربنا العالم احنا يعني ممكن الدكاتره
بيقولوا ان احنا ممكن نقعد شهر او شهور في
نفس الوضع
الوضع طبعا الاثر النفسي على الاسره سيء
جدا الاثر برده على الاولاد وعلي من حيث
المسؤوليات الحياه نفسها صعبه جدا عدم
وجوده دي حاجه قاسيه جدا مخاوف كتير
بتنتظرنا في المستقبل المستقبل مجهول الى
حد ما ربنا يا رب يحسن قدرنا ولكن
الى الان هو غير معروف فطبعا الوضع سيء ان
الحاله النفسيه للولد ابني عشان كان معاه
في الحادث الوضع حرج جدا برضه ايضا تم
استدعائه في النيابه للابداء باقواله طبعا
يعني النيابه كانوا ناس محترمين جدا وانا
بشكر النيابه وتعاونهم معانا وتقبلهم
لظروفنا لكن
الحدث نفسه اثره على الولد كان طبعا قاسي
جدا نفسيا
فاحنا الاسره بتعاني من حاجات كثيره جدا
بغض النظر عن الحاله الصحيه لجوز
نا له الف سلامه نتمنى يطلع بالسلامه شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معانا وروايه هذه
التفاصيل عبر الهاتف من القاهره زوجه
الضحيه التي تعرض لهجوم كلب مفترس
الدكتوره ايمان عبد المحسن ونشكر كذلك على
هذه الاضاحات المحامي بالنقد المستشار
محمد طاهر شكرا لكما